[Music]
o m to the g we are back with the
gorilla collective three-point fizz eye
if you were here for black voice and
gaming or gorilla collective 3 thanks
for tuning in supporting the devs and
the squad and welcome back i'm your host
justin woodward co-founder of the mix
the media indie exchange and i am with
my good and friend and partner from
wilmer's sound who hasn't been around
alex wilmer yes it is great to be with
you my good and friend
we're going to be making some magic
pop off that happened a bit of history
about the gorilla collective this is the
third year of the gorilla collective and
it was organized by the mix and other
publishing partners and friends during
the mask flopping booster shot stabbing
shutdown of 2020 to support the game
development culture from the vultures
and put something together since we can
no longer give each other hugs at events
oh my god
i love i love the love you know what i
mean we are developers and enthusiasts
supporting other folks in this space and
are honored to be here again before we
get started we have to give a huge shout
out to our illustrious sponsors
playstation razer astro gaming tencent
as well as our fellow devs and
publishers you see them up here they're
they're here all their glory amazing
also salute to the developers who
participated in the showcase they have
all contributed their time blood sweat
and tears and resources to make this
thing
possible we are just messengers
showcasing awesome content so shout out
to our broadcasting partners who are
helping us with this content and
supporting the showcase twitch steam ign
and of course gamespot you guys are
amazing
yes and the love continues so be sure to
check out the gorilla collective event
page on steam where you can learn more
about the games buy the games that are
available now and add the games that are
not available to your wish lists
that's really important that helps out
the developers definitely add those
games to the wish lists and buy them on
all the platforms possible
switch make sure to get them on
everything yeah every all of them you
know that would really help out the
developers
that'd be very friendly
we are coming at you with a barrage of
dope indie titles first starting with
some interesting gc picks and we'll end
our showcase with a glimpse of some
titles coming from japan with a
spotlight from our friends at bit summit
yes
let's go
blind
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
know
[Music]
hi i'm marco and i'm roman at iron lands
we are big fans of cyberpunk fiction and
games but we have our own ideas of what
a cyberpunk world can be
we're making a bright vibrant world
where you live your cyberpunk slice of
life run your business meet new people
make friends and enemies this is the
game in which you manage your restaurant
bar or nightclub take care of your staff
make deals farm and experience the
stories of the people you meet
or maybe you just want to take the day
off and go fishing at the docks instead
niwales primarily uses voxel art for the
environments we spend lots of time
creating a unique atmosphere with high
levels of detail and dynamic elements
but although we're filling the world
with interesting things to see and do
we're even more excited by your
creativity you'll customize your
apartment your restaurants bars and
nightclubs and make choices that will
change the lives of the people around
you
there's something very emotional about
the cyberpunk setting with its dystopian
but yet very colorful and inviting world
i think the most engaging thing to me
personally about nivalis is that it's a
world that never stops or sleeps there
is always something happening around you
the world is filled with dozens of
details that make it feel alive and real
we can't wait to see the choices you'll
make and how you'll choose to live your
life when you come visit us in niwalas
[Music]
hey boss time to wake up we got
customers waiting
what do you mean you don't know where to
start let's clean this place up move
some chairs and tables around we can
make this place shine again
if the weather gets bad we can grow some
veg in the greenhouse
once we start making real money well
then you can rent that fancy new
apartment in midtown
so make friends make enemies give
customers a route just turn on the old
charm or water down their drinks i'm not
your conscience
this is a world to explore
to make stories
your stories
you ever look up at the clouds and
wonder what's up there well if you dream
big enough maybe you'll find out maybe
we all will
welcome to nivalis
we are very happy to share with you our
upcoming adventure game lost in play
we wanted to create a game that will
recapture the spirit of play from our
childhood and look and feel like you are
playing a cartoon
lost in play is a feel-good adventure
play as totto and gal to explore
dreamscapes and befriend magical
creatures
on this journey they tackle difficult
situations that only together they can
get out of using their wits and courage
[Music]
we created over 30 different unique and
challenging mini games
we wanted to create an evolution of the
classic point and click adventure games
we used to play when we were kids
by making the gameplay much more fluid
and natural for modern day consoles
making the game feel at home both with a
game pad as well as with a mouse
having young kids of our own we aim to
create a game you can play with your
entire family where adults and children
can enjoy playing together
hello
[Music]
we chose to have all the dialogues in
gibberish in order to concentrate on
visual storytelling
and because it's fun
[Music]
allow yourself to get lost in your
imagination
allow yourself to get lost in play
in play will be available for nintendo
switch and pc this summer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
welcome to the internet world of
glitchbusters the world of glitchbusters
is currently under attack by mysterious
viruses known as glitches
together with your friends you will play
glitch busters in a four player co-op
third-person shooter action game
your goal is to defeat viruses and
glitches including trolls like you can
see here on your way to discover the
secret behind the virus outbreak and the
glitches themselves during your
adventures sometimes you'll run into
certain objects that are out of your
reach in cases like these you'll want to
take advantage of the magnetic co-op
system that defines glitch busters you
can stack on top of your allies and
reach high locations by stacking on top
of each other here we can find the
switch that allows us to move forward as
you move through glitch busters you'll
need to think about creative ways to
defeat large groups of villains at once
take advantage of your surroundings work
together for the best results use the
magnetic qual system to climb on top of
walls pipes as well as to climb on top
of your allies once you reach a high
location not only can you shoot the
enemy you can also drop down on them in
order to destroy them here we see the
ufo elevator use this to reach high
locations to find the path forward
sometimes even when you intend to
cooperate together you can get into each
other's way you'll also find other ai as
you move through the world of
witchbusters you'll have other game
modes including this side-scrolling mode
here you'll need to be careful that your
allies aren't trying to keep you from
collecting the most likes while being
sure to dodge obstacles as they come
towards you as you run into other crew
tubers listen to what they have to say
they may give you important hints to
help you discover exactly what is
occurring in the city and elsewhere
causing this viral outbreak most of the
living creatures within the world of
glitchbusters are based on emoji you as
the player will also have the
opportunity to customize your character
with different emoji faces our main goal
is to have a game that has players
talking amongst themselves and bringing
back the feeling of couch co-op that
defined many of our childhoods as a
member of the rescue squad one of your
jobs is to collect as many likes as you
can a player who collects the most likes
will have the best chance of becoming
the mvp at the end of the level of
course if you want to keep all the likes
to yourself you can also play this game
entirely solo or with only two or three
people glitch busters will feature four
player split screen and local
multiplayer as well so you don't
necessarily have to be on the internet
to play sometimes you'll need to use
these special usb keys in order to
proceed through the level switchbusters
may be a cooperative action game but
every once in a while it may be in your
best interest or you may simply just be
in the mood to throw your allies under
the bus once you've freed up cloudy the
manager of the servers here that will be
the end of the stage and you'll be able
to proceed to the next one
[Music]
thanks for watching and don't forget to
pick up glitchbusters later on this year
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh let's try that again
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow novalis is oozing with that
cyberpunk style it looks so clean the
lighting uh and the 3d grass dope the
block is looking real fresh and crispy
too we're going to take a little bit of
an intermission
because we have an announcement to make
the team at the mix is celebrating our
10th year anniversary and it has been
quite a ride putting together showcase
broadcasts like this one and in-person
events all over the world has been
incredible when i helped to start the
mix i was a budding developer and
entrepreneur grinding alongside my indie
friends looking to get our teams just a
little bit of shine and recognition our
mission from day one was to blow up
amazing indie titles and have the
talented folks behind them get some love
we have had the honor of working with
some of the best teams publishers and
partners in the business and are proud
to keep that tradition going and flowing
through our evolving vision
with this in mind we are proud to
announce the mixed games where we will
be further partnering with developers
and our publishing friends to develop
publish and create inclusive
opportunities for developers to grow we
will rock this out by delivering full
multi-platform experiences through
development financial support
manufacturing distribution and marketing
help this is an exciting opportunity we
will be teasing now
and we'll have more info later
let's get back to the show
up next our second stack of games where
we'll be sharing an up-and-coming title
from the humble games family and get
foxy
with an update from a slick animal-based
adventure on its release horizon
let's roll
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in words of ravage combat is at the
heart of the game
you'll have to face powerful champions
from different realms
don't expect to defeat them in a single
fight
there are a lot of ways to approach the
combat
you can try to create a carry for your
squad sacrificing other units to do so
you can focus on damage over time
you can use global abilities called
edicts
[Music]
can weaken enemies and send your
powerful leader to finish them
or you could come up with more creative
combinations utilizing the mechanics of
individual skills
each of your units
has support tank or damage dealer
but the way in which it fulfills its
role is also important different tanks
for example can control damage in
different ways
some can reduce the damage an enemy does
while others can resurrect you in battle
making any health bonus more potent
you can make any combination that fits
your playstyle
and become one of the lords of ravage
i'm eli the developer of wanderlost and
today we're going to be taking a quick
look at some gameplay
wanderlust is a survival rpg set in an
unusually cheerful post apocalypse so
you can see here i'm putting the final
touches on my base
i'm using a stone floor because wood can
actually catch on fire and if i want to
place a fire pit down so that i can cook
inside my base stone is going to keep me
pretty safe
i'm going to place a window here as well
so that i can keep an eye on any zombies
going by especially once i get a roof
put in
that'll that'll keep me a little bit
safer
roofs are are what keep the weather off
your back so that can be important
my hunger meter is not doing that great
and i don't have much food stored so i
am going to go and place a couple traps
down there are a lot of different ways
to get food in wanderlust placing small
traps to catch game like rabbits and
squirrels can be really effective if you
have the time to wait for them another
really good way to get food is to go
fishing if you've got the supplies and i
do have the supplies i actually keep a
separate bag containing my fishing
supplies which you saw me switch there i
can just toss a new backpack on in order
to switch between different loadouts so
now i've got my fishing backpack on
and you can see those bubbles are where
any fish are that was actually a big
part of why i built this base where i
did because it had easy access to a good
fishing location nearby casting into the
deep water because that's where the
larger fish are found took me a couple
casts but i did get a good spot with the
fish and we have caught a mackerel so
now now that i have the fish i do need
to cook it i also need to debone the
fish so cooking and fire making in
wanderlust is important for a variety of
reasons fires are going to keep you warm
weather is a significant challenge in
the game depending on which biome you
build in and and i actually built in the
boreal forest biome which is an
especially cold one
so you can see i'm starting a fire right
now using a lighter a lighter is
actually one of the easiest tools
they're kind of rare but you can find
them from zombies and loot fire makers
don't last forever so if you have one
it will run out but you can always craft
more if there are primitive tools like
hand drills and bow drills
now i'm just going to cook this fish up
once i eat this that's going to improve
my health regeneration and it's going to
give me a health boost that lasts for
maybe about an hour or so in game and
with hunger taken care of we can focus
on other things like expanding our base
exploring some of the abandoned towns
and fighting the zombies that reside
there leveling up and even completing
quests for our friends over in halcyon
[Music]
thanks for joining me to take a look at
wanderlost
[Music]
hello is anyone there
[Music]
guess we're taking the ghost at a ghost
town huh kid
i've always wanted to visit new orleans
i'm not like this
[Music]
nice one
[Music]
that's not my home
that's my hell
just for you
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
get ready for the new and awesome
edition of
kung fury street rage
a day at the beach
what could possibly be more epic than a
true hero
another hero
double trouble
enjoy the breathtaking multiplayer as
player 2 joins the fight
yeah two
because teamwork makes the dream work
play as hasselhoff the world's most
iconic lifeguard steps in with his
singing prowess and oh that's some nice
chest there sir
more action more awesome
this game just has more
choose your stage punch nazis in the
sewers on the beach in the viking age
they'll punch nazis everywhere all the
time
come fury street rage
soon available on a platform near you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
rated m for mature
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hahaha
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
wow shout out to humble games for coral
island that is an exquisite game looks
so good chefs kisses all around for sure
shout out to neon doctor for holding it
down make sure to wish list all of those
games of course and pick up my lovely
wife when it is
ready
and available
for our last segment we are going to
blast through some more games starting
with an update from a deductive wizard
simulator check out some new takes on
the strategy genre and then catch up
with games from our friends at bit
summit with their anticipated gc 3.5
indie picks oh yeah let's go
[Music]
hello there and welcome to evil as your
mayor let me be the first to say this is
a safe place
[Music]
mare dead
they don't last very long around here
this used to be a quiet peaceful place
times have changed
these days
no one is safe
not even in their own homes
and the conspirators are to blame
they lurk in the shadows and strike
when nobody's watching
however
hope is not lost each one of you
possesses remarkable skills that will
aid in your quest for justice special
abilities that not only help you uncover
the conspirators but also prove your
innocence
you'll have to trap spy and even kill to
help ensure your survival for some of
you
why be so lucky
fear not
because even in the afterlife you can
aid your fellow villagers
you must work together and find the
conspirators hiding in plain sight but
the information you've gathered cast
your vote to eliminate the reekers of
havoc
and restore order to evil
that's unless
you're one of them
[Music]
foreign
which
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
greetings your majesty and welcome to
the unforgiving world of orcs in orcs
your primary goal is to protect your
kingdom against the hordes of ruthless
orcs
if your main castle falls it means the
kingdom is lost
if you manage to defeat every wave of
orcs it means you live to fight another
day
you'll have some troops of your own but
you can't rely on them to defeat the
orcs you will always be outnumbered so
the only reliable way to get rid of them
is to build some more castles
to build something you need to pick a
card from your hand and place it on a
map
be strategic about it you should always
consider from which direction the orcs
are planning to attack this time
a castle consists of several parts so
you would need more than one card to
complete it
build it as large as you want
a finished castle can be upgraded with
rooms additional towers
and special buildings to make it shoot
faster deal more damage or even get a
new type of attack
[Music]
the more castles you have the more
chances for you to repel the next wave
of enemies
there are some mysterious structures on
the map those are the vaults if you
complete its quest it may reward you
with some new cards you can add to your
deck
[Music]
deck building is an essential part of
orcs
you'll get the chance to upgrade certain
cards slowly creating a perfect deck
that will suit your playstyle
two campaigns won't ever feel the same
thanks to the roguelike nature of the
game if you fail you can always try
again but this time with new cards in
the starting deck or you can try out one
of the other factions each with a unique
play style
so good luck to you your majesty i would
wish you a long reign but let's keep it
real i can already hear the orcs
approaching
[Music]
hey there my name is thomas waterswood
and i'm the developer of please touch
the artwork what would happen if you did
touch the artwork
that's the question i wanted to explore
in this game this resulted in three
unique narrative puzzle experiences all
inspired by art movement the style and
more specifically paintings from pete
mondrian make no mistake thinking this
is a serious game that explains every
detail of the art of mondrian it's more
about the enjoyment of the visuals the
music and the stories behind the
paintings together with a little bit of
cozy puzzling it uses modern art to tell
modern stories
both anecdotal fictitious and
autobiographical
both quirky lighthearted and bittersweet
game number one tells you about the
creation of abstract art using a story
inspired on the genesis story from the
bible instead of creating the earth
we'll be creating a canvas and primary
color you'll have to add colors and
lines to the canvas to reproduce the
painting on the left
let me quickly fast forward so you can
see some more of the levels by the way
all content is procedurally generated
game number two tells the story of
boogie and woogie
two squares who just want to be together
but a rapidly growing world is making
this harder and harder you'll have to
help woogie reach boogie by figuring out
how the obstacles influence rookie's pop
it's actually a modern romeo and juliet
adaptation that addresses racial
inequality
you choose an entrance and woogie
automatically moves forward the color
blocks will then change woogie's
direction
game number three it's a visual poem
about moving to the big city full of
excitement and high hopes only to be
overwhelmed with mixed emotions from joy
and excitement to feeling homesick and
missing your friends and family
please touch the artwork it's all about
relaxing there's no time pressure no
skills required you can play in short
sessions
the game doesn't punish you but engages
you to try out stuff to progress by
trial and error which is a metaphor for
the creative process
the game won best art at tokyo game show
most impact at brazilian indie developer
game conference and was featured by
eurogamer and news outlet the guardian
in the top 20 games from 2022 so far
it's also nominated as a finalist for
the apple design awards so i'm very
grateful for that and i hope it might
convince some of you to buy and play it
oh yes indeed it's already available now
on steam apple app store and google play
and it will be released on switched
early this summer
and a little exclusive secret
it will be coming to vr as well
but don't tell him
[Music]
ah
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
great
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
wow
this
uh
[Music]
we're back much gratitude to john davis
and the bit summit team for sharing
their picks for gc3 yes i cannot wait to
go back to bits on it i can't wait to go
back to kyoto it's been too long that
concludes the gorilla collective 3.5
thanks once again to our sponsors and
broadcasting partners for their support
playstation razer astro gaming and 10
cent thank you also so much twitch game
spot valve and ign for hosting the
stream yeah and be sure to check out the
gorilla collective event page on steam
where you can learn more about these
games
buy the games that are available now or
add games that are not available to your
wish lists yes definitely do that
thanks to the scrappy and illustrious
mix team media one and of course wilmer
sound
my amazing co-host thank you so much
it's been so long
it has
thank you justin yes and uh where can we
find you in the team yes you can find us
on instagram at wilmer sound or on
twitter at real wilmer sound definitely
check out wilmerson
also once again
my name is justin woodward co-founder of
the mix you can follow gorilla
collective on twitter at gorilla collect
everywhere else at gorilla collective in
the mix on twitter at indiexchange and
everywhere else at media indie exchange
thank you so much for joining us this
concludes gorilla collective 3.5 and
three we will see you really soon
peace
[Music]
you